olá bom dia angola afonso lima sobre o
flamengo ea faz parte do clã
quando fui convidado para vir aqui falar
até que pensar para o que é que eu vou
conseguir falar tantas coisas que nós
fazemos que eu vou te falar e eu queria
partilhar a segurança enquanto o avaí
que parecem partilhar
mas a primeira conclusão que cheguei
aqui há cinco anos não é uma boa idéia
que merece ser partilhada nem sequer é
propriamente uma idéia não é que seja
uma coisa má
mas ela não surgiu de uma idéia e já
tinha aceite o convite resolvi ir falar
com os meus amigos alega que kassab está
volta
quando falei com ela olhamos para o país
temas a serra gaúcha e percebemos que
realmente era isso que estava sempre
surge 60 tudo aquilo que nós fazemos nós
unimos porque criamos partilhar coisas
nós fazemos as coisas porque conseguimos
partilhar todos os meios que nós temos
para conseguir fazer acontecer
então é que o companheiro e apresentados
os trabalhos é k é como as coisas foram
acontecendo e como é que eu cheguei à
conclusão de que realmente partilhar uma
boa ideia e como é que nós a partir daí
conseguimos trabalhar em conjunto
é difícil saber quando é que as gráficas
com o som a foi um movimento quase
espontâneo nós sabemos que existem
várias pessoas que vão com suas idéias a
partir disso criar nem se conheciam e
qualquer coisa no fundo todos nós temos
em comum que eram um gosto muito grande
pela arte e pela cultura da música
essencialmente uma vontade de fazer
coisas aconteceram neste domingo ao
momento que ocorre muito bem e para mim
é crucial nessa só vai falar comigo e
mostrou uma música e um desafio apenas
nessa música faz mais uma senhora vamos
lançar um álbum que os problemas com as
todas as pessoas que já tiveram uma
idéia a apontou que é primeira não sei
se é menina e assim tão interessante
essa música que eu faço é assim tão boa
não seria algo assim tão boa e não sei
se tem os recursos necessários para
conseguir fazer isto
quanto à primeira pergunta a minha
resposta é e responde com outra gente
nunca vai saber se vão tentar fazer e
acima tudo isso é uma coisa que tu
vale a pena fazer isso aí eu fui o cara
vai fazer um álbum mas não saí já também
vai estar aqui o quanto a outra parte
não saber se temos recurso o que
corresponde foi pato - eu já gosto disso
e vou tentar ajudar a fazer isso e vamos
partilhar este sair com mais pessoas e
foi o que fizemos e ao fazermos isso
preparamos a que as pessoas realmente
quiseram envolver se neste projecto
entre as pessoas a fazer a captação
emprestar a sala a cantarem no próprio
álbum a fazer em arte gráfica a escrever
esta história partilharem e conseguimos
realmente atingir nosso objetivo que o
um momento em que se tornou muito mais
entanto que é enquanto nós estamos nessa
dinâmica partilhar aquilo que tínhamos
paramos que havia pessoas também estavam
envolvidas neste projecto
kan sentiram que era um espaço onde
podiam desenvolver as suas ideias como
podia desenvolver os seus alvos em
movimento ou outro em vez de termos um
álbum já tem uns três e se desfazer foi
ok vamos então criar uma matriz leva ea
começar a divulgar o nosso trabalho
além disso também surgiu a idéia do
festival vamos organizar os tentar
arranjar maneira de organizar um
festival começar a divulgar as músicas
que nós prestamos atenção estamos isso
penso que nós fazemos
éramos um minuto porque não é um amigo e
pessoas que eles vão ficar por aqui mas
nós ganhamos porque quando começamos a
partilhar a opções que foram sendo tiso
um sentindo atraídas a vida em colaborar
connosco ea uma história específica
domingo nós agora nós vivíamos envolve
uma das nossas músicas e estou e com
certeza sobre nós e decidiu partilhar
connosco que tinha a ver o que podia
fazer e mandou nos países
os dias música é imensa música e ouvimos
e gostamos daquilo que plantamos
e eu pergunto então agora querem fazer a
resposta foi quase enviado foi nós vamos
fazer o que quisesse e nesse momento eu
senti o que realmente tem espaço para
conseguir explorar as suas ideias ea
parte mais interessante ainda acontece
e é essa pessoa porque sentia que podia
expor as suas ideias porque viam pessoas
aqui disponíveis para ajudar a
concretizar também sentiu aquela vontade
de partilhar aquilo que sabia fazer com
as outras pessoas de forma a colaborar
ea transformar as idéias uns dos outros
e conseguirem atingir mais resultados
mas gravar mais discos fazer mais
concertos ao vivo e depois disso
acontecer outra coisa e parece desculpa
tempo em que dia porque realmente são
cinco anos de história é que tudo aqui é
tentar pensar em pouquíssimo tempo
isso aconteceu também um final muito
santo que foi daquelas idéias que nós
tenhamos inicialmente por exemplo vamos
fazer uma banda para travar um a um
disco e lançá lo ia seguir lá concertos
nós fizemos uma coisa de enfrentamento
que foi o primeiro álbum que não o que é
o nome que vai gravar meu não tinha
andado um tema com 37 momento nós
olhamos em vez de fazer o disco aquilo
que fizemos foi vamos juntar uma banda
para tocar as músicas do nosso capital e
foi aqui que nós percebemos é que a
cidade não é propriamente uma isaias
embates foi acontecendo
não porque era uma ideia de negócio não
porque era uma ideia estéticas quer em
termos de organização que vamos ter mas
sim porque nós disponibilizamos a
partilhar certa forma que não estamos a
partilhar como uma família partilha e
até muitas vezes nós aprendamos
assegurados como uma família e ao
disponibilizarmos as coisas foram
acontecendo e transformar em sair até
sugira que este coletivo que nós temos
então que eu posso usar da minha
experiência em gerenciamento foi aquilo
que eu fui aprendendo com ao longo deste
processo e as idéias que foi tendo e
foram foram ficando na face tendo
pensamentos como é que eu aprendi a
trabalhar em conjunto sempre melhor
então primeira mensagem que queria
deixar sua marca pela concessionária
possa agilizar isso não precisam ser a
última coca cola do deserto não precisam
vencer
também testemunhais tem que ser a causa
de vocês acreditam da mesma forma que é
meu amigo não mostrou uma música e oque
decidimos avançar maior parte das idéias
só precisam de um contexto um contexto
para que se possam desenvolver isso
acontece em casa e se transformam em
alguma coisa é o contexto do processo
criativo e uma coisa muito importante
que eu aprendi seu processo criativo é
que este é um processo onde as idéias
são construídas sucessivamente em
portanto torna 11 um processo que é de
partilha e ela sempre de alguma forma um
processo coletivo
todo mundo que eu conheci em algum
momento em que estava uma criança de 10
anos cidade partilhar a sua ideia e com
essa partilha conseguiram transformar o
exemplo mais gritante som os músicos que
tocam em banda e que eu passava ensaios
começam a guitarrista com essa tá com
uma linha o baixista começado catalunha
por cima ser baterista toca outra coisa
ea seguir o guitarrista já para que
tenha espaço para desenvolver outras
coisas e assim vai sucedendo o processo
criativo até criar uma nova música
mesmos aftra o sol maior parte dos lados
voltando à experiência e também pessoal
é que há sempre um momento em que vão
ficar as pensões vão buscar aí as outras
pessoas e vamos transformando as nossas
ideias e outras plantas transformam para
nós temos então pessoas envolvidas nesta
partida aqui o processo criativo
existe uma coisa também aprendi que
existe sempre algo que naquelas pessoas
que é uma motivação comum no nosso caso
era o gosto pela música vontade de
partilhar em outros casos outros terão
outras intervenções
e foi nesse caso aquela vontade de fazer
coisas na música que fez para voltas
alguma da criação de um álbum fez nos a
seguir para criarmos tudo aquilo que
tínhamos e às vezes até que não tínhamos
para conseguir que o álbum fosse pra
frente e nos levou a criar isto e
circuito digamos assim de partilha onde
outras pessoas também conseguiram sentir
teve espaço para fazer em seus projetos
e sobre estes circuitos partilha que são
mais de 500 redes de partilha onde nós
estamos a partilhar as nossas ideias do
nosso conhecimento o nosso
o que fazemos para que seja divulgado o
circuito que são alimentados
constantemente pura é pela não só pelas
ideias mas também pela organização que
nós damos às pessoas
estes circuitos são o espaço ideal para
ajudar e que equivale a isso
tal como nos aconteceu do que quando nós
estávamos na dinâmica construir coisas a
voltas a todos os cursos
partilhávamos houve pessoas que olharam
fora e perceberam que tinham espaço para
expor as suas ideias e finalmente eu
também percebi que as melhores idéias
são aquelas que não têm dono e com isso
não quer dizer que eu não venho lá
tinham a as pessoas têm base estava há
pessoas genuinamente enviadas mas
essencialmente porque o que eu consegui
ficar tudo aquilo que nós fizemos foi e
olhando para trás é que os meus projetos
aconteceram quando a isso se minozzo tal
forma pelo coletivo que se perdeu há a
noção de quem é que pertencia àquela
idéia original daí passou a ser presença
de cada um de nós e de todos em conjunto
então tivemos mais pessoas responsáveis
para conseguir levar a que os projectos
até ao fim e conseguiu tivessem algum
impacto final meta principal mensagem
que eu tive essa minha experiência é cá
trabalhar em conjunto é sempre melhor do
que fazer as coisas sozinho uma partida
fácil explicar sobre isto que é parte do
que quando estamos a trabalhar sozinho
estamos limitados a as nossas ideias os
nossos recursos à nossa disponibilidade
e quando trabalhamos em conjunto como
precisamos sair daí todo o processo de
desenvolver a multiplicar pelo número de
pessoas estão envolvidas conosco um a um
todos estes recursos toda a
disponibilidade e isso ditou o sucesso
do dos nossos projetos
mas acima de tudo a um ponto e que já
foi falado 2 manhã o pedro
essencialmente nós aqui estamos a falar
de coisas coisas que é criar um impacto
que o impacto
nas pessoas como falou agora o nono
criar um impacto cria memórias coisa que
prevaleçam no tempo e uma das coisas que
aprendi é que fazer as coisas em
conjunto realmente falam sempre muito
mais apenas sabe sempre o melhor
ou esta semana o único do nosso coletivo
que deu uma entrevista que falava da
idéias há pelo menos um miúdo que
sentimos antes dos concertos antes de
uma apresentação desde a viagem tem os
momentos
óptimos momentos que antecedem e eu
dizia que o sofá e partilhar com pessoas
que iam fazer também a mesma coisa
partilhar a viagem partilhada é que o
fim dos segundos antes já tranquiliza a
mais e dava uma energia que eu conseguia
lavar para o concerto de transmitir isso
também para as pessoas em volta
isso são coisas que não são mensuráveis
isso isso essencialmente nos rios das
pessoas
como falamos apresentar no início nós
fazemos um festival e é neste valor que
nós temos mas a noção do que realmente
vale a pena e as coisas saíram melhor em
conjunto tanto a isso aqui com um
pequeno vídeo que é focada especialmente
nas pessoas estiveram na organização e
que mostra então vamos tentar mostrar
que tantos sorrisos realmento fazer as
coisas em conjunto a pena
obrigado
d